ladies and gentlemen Nick margarita from
GameSpot here I am joined by the four
time NBA champion three-time NBA Finals
MVP the 1993 Rookie of the Year a master
of Shaq foo Shaquille O'Neal lazy gel
men
oh you know fellas
so so shocked we got a we got a game
coming coming up pretty soon he tell us
a little bit about a legend reborn I
played video games all throughout
college and the technology back then was
you know blocks and little sounds and
wasn't a lot of stuff so when I into the
NBA and a company approaches it lets do
a video game similar to that all my guys
in the dorms were playing this style
analog style video game but it's one
word that I didn't anticipate or I
didn't hear digital so I think 94 95 was
the birth of the digital age where you
know better graphics and color screen
and this and that so my gang got kind of
lost in the shuffle but still I kind of
classic that game and for 20 25 years
people have asked me to redo it so
finally I got with a company it's here
so 2014 IndieGoGo there's a campaign
that shows up for kind of a remake a not
so much a remake but kind of a legend
reborn I guess you could say it's in the
title so how much involvement did you
have and bring that campaign about they
saved my my idea I just wanted to engage
people's interest to see if people still
wanted wanted to see the game and you
know a good thing about me is you know
you've been in business with a guy like
me I do not micromanage so if I wanted
to start a service or we interview get
video game people I'm not gonna be
telling you how to do your job you go
out and do your job and then I threat
successful we both take the credit so I
got with guys that do coding you gave me
new graphics you know guys that do this
stuff for 11
I will get to see the final product and
you know make make some tweaks but you
know if I was able to do everything by
myself then I would do it by myself but
I thought I Billy so you know the
Masters do what they do
[Music]
now about giant cactus who designed this
game the reviews in 1994 pretty
interesting for Shaq foo so this time
around what are the biggest differences
or biggest improvements that make this
game stand out graphics better storyline
and it looks real all the characters are
funny
we don't worry about reviews reviews
with all that's right unless you unless
you play the game like I want to hear
the reviews from the guys that play the
game not from the guys who sit around it
the job is just review stuff oh you know
I want to have a review from my kids
kids friends kids children guys that
play the game and it's only two reviews
you can get while this game sucks our
game is pretty nice that's all I want to
hear I don't want to really hear nothing
else so hopefully it's only this game is
pretty good sign
we kind of have a little game here you
play with us
so you and I Charles Barkley have been
kind of a viral meme you could say
recently because you told Chuck to quote
Google you right is that correct
[Music]
we actually googled you and we were
wondering if you could answer some of
Google's autocomplete questions he's
Shaq a doctor yes yes he's a doctor
confirmed okay number two is Shaq a
police officer I'm not allowed to say
that because I may be on the cover I
might not okay if what is Shaq's shoe
son 22 oh my god I'm a size eight that's
terrifying
okay did Aaron Carter actually beat Shaq
yes he did he did confirmed
[Music]
we were playing like a game of one-shot
horse Aaron Carter Backstreet Boys NSYNC
that was just they actually recorded the
first album at my house so I Erin came
by said if I hit this shot you do a song
with me I said well I'm not worried
about you hitting the shadows I of
course shot in the editor store and
that's how I got to be able song holy
cow Aaron Carter did beat Shaq okay
number six is Shaq a DJ just wore one oh
all right number seven and Shaq rap of
course can we get a little rap of course
not
is Shaq foo better than Barkley shut up
and jam I'm only five I'm 40 although my
46 years old I'm just not hearing that
Charles Barkley had a game so the answer
is hell yes all right this is the this
is the final question this is this is it
from Google it's it's more of a personal
one would can we show the audience how
much smaller I am than you by letting me
sit on your lap like Santa Claus
Shakeel thank you so much for for
letting us come and ask you questions
and bother you we really appreciate it
and this has been an absolute dream come
true for me
thank you alright thank you guys and
keep it right here at GameSpot for all
your Shaq foo of legend reborn news
[Music]